breaking news everyone breaking news
breaking news hold on to your butts New
deus ex video games coming out
apparently at Justin hey Walt explain
the title of this game well so for a
while we've known something is up the
square has been doing a stream on Twitch
yes and it's been really weird they're
stretching it over three days kind of
assumed was deus ex say that you come
the kind of guess have they cut it short
and well no no it's still going alright
thank you sign for it yeah well then a
russian site was like here are some
pictures of the games great hey there's
a new deus ex called mankind divided on
xbox one ps4 pc and then it turns out
while game informer has the the full
cover spread the next issue of game
informer you gonna be able to read a
whole bunch of info on the game and
interviews the developers and so they
also just came out and go yeah yeah the
games out that this is what the next
game is going to be here's our cover
story and so we don't really know a
whole lot right now we know that data
sex mankind divided is going to follow
adam jensen the guy from human
revolution and it's set like a few years
after a human revolution after human
revolution and there was a problem with
like them sending out people that have
all the augmentations to kill lots of
people hmm and so we don't say people
aren't really happy about that and so
mankind is you might say divide it
divided hmm it's almost like they're
they're like x-men and then human the
mutants and the humans and they're gonna
fight or like deus ex two invisible war
which was kind of the same concept Sofia
way more factions and Templars and weird
warren's are yeah yeah essence and kevin
van noord you're a fan of human
revolution oh yeah this sequel I know I
know you didn't ask for us oh shut up I
know I know you didn't ask where Kevin I
didn't ask for this but but I excited
for it well yeah I mean but I mean
that's the thing deus ex as a has an
interesting history I mean everybody
everybody loved the first deus ex that
was great even even though it was like
it was even even then it was one of the
uglier games you could get better yeah
it was really great
only different paths to take and what
not one of the best like early first
person role playing and also practical
shooter like only did a bunch of really
great stuff on the same package I like
the second one yeah the jail I you know
you know why I'm gonna back up invisible
war yeah and say that's that game was
was really good on its own terms I i
think it was like an 80 on Metacritic or
something really open though fans when
overboard I mean it was poorly optimized
I had a dumb ammo system yeah and there
were there were problems with that game
you know I really I really like that
game and I think human revolution is a
nice improvement on Invisible War I
don't think was hardly it was hardly a
perfect game it's almost an entire great
type of game human Revolution it's like
a cover shooter linear like it wasn't in
terms of the role-playing stuff days in
the previous two games yeah they did a
really good job with that though I
really liked it but I think if there's
anything I think if there's one thing I
want them to do it's get out of this you
know a bunch of boxes all connected
together sort of design and small
explorable areas with lots of you know
curly q you know vents and shaft ways to
get through I'd really like to see that
opened up but that game struggled even
in some of those small spaces and run so
well this one's going to be coming out
to current gen systems Alex one ps4 pc
probably unlike human Revolution which
had a later version that came out for
the wii u guess this one doesn't do that
but if you want to get human Revolution
get the wii u version but what because
seriously because it has so I love
developer commentary yes and it's got
developer commentary on it there's
actually a lot of fun to listen to you
know I love peeks into the development
process like that and they're too rare
so yeah get that version especially
because the gamepad actually makes the
hacking better nice yeah and mankind
divided obviously we've only seen the
screenshots that are now available on
gamespot com hopefully it'll be some
more information over the next coming
week
you